ugh the holidays are finally upon us
which means it's the season for
cookies
welcome to the holiday cookie showdown
with us your favorite buzzfeed hosts
hannah and joyce four amateur bakers
will compete in unique cookie challenges
in order to crown the ultimate holiday
baker let the competition begin
i love my job
[Music]
hi everyone it's joyce and hannah and
today we're starting our search for the
best holiday cookie baker this series
will challenge four hand-picked bakers
to create their best holiday cookies on
the themes of tradition decorating and
flavor this baking competition is
sponsored by shipt the delivery service
making the holidays easier for all home
chefs i can't live without it personally
i'm very excited for this let's welcome
our bakers welcome baker
welcome to the holiday cookies showdown
today's challenge you'll be making your
favorite traditional holiday cookie and
hannah and i will judge your cookies
will be judged on taste presentation and
holiday essence we love a festive cookie
and as much as it pains me to say this i
don't want to say it
after we taste your cookies one of you
will be going home today no
i know i don't want you to yeah but you
better work
okay i want you to put everything in
this cookie okay i want to fill your
family holiday when i take a bite
and you only have one hour to do this so
let's get started
[Music]
hello i'm roland jefferson my favorite
part about the holidays is actually just
spending time with friends and family
like food always brings people closer
together i am making a chocolate crinkle
cookie because it's traditional to the
holidays and
memories and themes and things that i
like to bring to the holidays
so i'm making ginger snaps hi my name is
eliana i'm from oxford california and i
live in los angeles i love to bake i've
been baking my whole life since i was a
little kid i worked at bakeries growing
up in high school and when i was 17 i
was the california state cake decorating
champion i'm like if i don't win and i'm
flexing so
this is like water
what skim milk
[Laughter]
fat-free milk
fat-free milk and a cookie
hi my name is benji
i've been baking
[Music]
as long as i can remember
i'm making snowball cookies or as i like
to call them mexican wedding cookies i'm
mexican and i grew up eating these a lot
during the holidays
i feel like i forgot how to read
suddenly hi i'm caroline kim my favorite
thing about baking for the holidays is
that i can watch my whole family gather
around and enjoy the things that i've
created for them today i'll be making
linzer cookies which are kind of like a
jam cookie sandwich listen to this
this asmr
oh
that's actually really good asmr that's
soothing it's smelling really good i
don't know about y'all
i think i need a bigger knife to cut
this
these nuts are not smashing and i have
this knife that is not used correctly
for this like nut so what am i gonna do
i have to use something to smash them so
that the judges aren't gonna be chunking
into something big my grandma she gets
in there with when she's baking like
full body arms are in here she has the
strongest hands ever please please speak
over this pounding
so i finished really early i was baking
putting everything into the oven before
everybody else was even near baking
their their cookies so i'm making the
judge's names or their initials in the
dough to have something fun for them to
see on the plate oh that's so cute
i wanted to make something a little
extra for them
maybe i should too
i was a little bit worried about my
presentation because i started noticing
that the other contestants
grabbed all these little garnishes to
put on top so i was just like oh my god
mine are pretty simple
rolling pin brush
i'm feeling pressed for time things are
kind of crumbling literally like the um
dough is really crumbly
so it might not be cold enough yeah so
i'm trying to
piece it back together
what would you like me to do um the
spirit of the holiday is just everybody
coming together and i felt like that's
what i needed to do for her my
grandmother and my mother were always
hosting like holiday events or just
celebrations and so i would find myself
being in the kitchen with them picking
up tricks and little tips that i could
use on my own
i love that everyone stepped in to help
me i feel like it was an extra bonding
moment
oh save the top and just step away
[Applause]
you guys are amazing
hello bakers hey hey
this is the moment we've been eagerly
awaiting what time is it joyce i think
it's cookie o'clock it's 50 o'clock um
eliana do you want to start so i made
ginger snap cookies and i can't wait for
you to try them they're my personal
favorite
it's my name
okay wow you were really a teacher's pet
growing up oh yeah totally
okay so remember we're judging these on
taste presentation and holiday essence i
can't believe i have to go first because
they don't have anything to compare with
yet that's moisture
because it's chewy
and it's soft but it still has that like
snappy flavor you know i've never had a
ginger snap but damn this ginger snapped
one two three
it's really good i think i'm just
missing a little like salt i like the
fact that it says hoe
so
[Laughter]
all right raleigh let's see your cookie
all right i'm ready for you beautiful
these are my chocolate crinkle cookies
a little bit of chocolate a little bit
of cookie a little bit of snowflakes on
top
we were just having a conversation about
how i don't like chocolate chips
i like this kind of chocolate cookie you
like decadent chocolate
one two three wait
very tasty very rich a little on the
crispy side i kind of like a softer
cookie but the chocolaty flavor is so
rich and delicious i just want a glass
of milk or oat milk
for us who can't have milk products
beautiful beautiful spray i'm in a like
a half cookie coma right now it's the
same oh but next up we got ready for the
next one about to wake you up i thought
i'd give you guys some extra nut to dip
into like an interactive cookie
when i saw the judges eating my cookies
i knew that they were gonna like the
texture because i did taste it ahead of
time it was great
yeah i think i'm gonna win
this cookie
tubs at my heartstrings it reminds me of
my grandma and it almost just kind of
dissolves in your mouth
i let his cookie i love this cookie one
two three
overall
stunning cookies yes thank you thank you
so much yeah final cookie character
let's see what you got
wow
these are beautiful wow
cheers
oh my god
wow
[Music]
i got cookie delirious spot on spot on
[Music]
all around delicious cookies
[Music]
congratulations to caroline you got the
highest score
i'm really happy that i did so well on
the first day i was coming in really
nervous and i think that i'm going out
today feeling a little bit more
confident and ready for tomorrow's
baking adventure
and then next up we have eliana your
cookies were wonderful they were joy and
we really loved how you put your
personality into it thank you the next
person that i name will be safe and the
other person that is not named
unfortunately be going home
both of your cookies were amazing it was
really difficult for hannah and i so the
person who will be moving on to the next
challenge is
benji
oh congratulations
thank you we loved your cookies so much
i was a little sad in the moment but it
was a great experience it just helped me
realize some things that i can work on
when i'm in the kitchen and hopefully
help me in the future
thanks for tuning in to our first
episode of the holiday cookie showdown
make sure to check out our next episode
to see who makes it into the final round
see you next time bye